[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers einen
guten Sonntagabend ihnen allen wir
beginnen heute mit dem Ende nachher in
der Sendung sind wir bei vorfreudigen
Partys in Hollywood dabei wo ein
deutscher Film heute Nacht abräumen kann
wie nie zuvor im Rennen um die Oscars
ein Film der das Grauen des Ersten
Weltkriegs zeigt in kompromisslosen
Bildern im Westen nichts Neues im Osten
erinnert aktuell wieder viel an den
Horror des Stellungskrieges den wir
eigentlich für immer hinter uns lassen
wollten
abnutzungsschlacht das grauenhafte Wort
steht für die Lage in bachmut Ukraine wo
jeder Meter vor und zurück horrende
Opfer fordert die politische Führung in
Kiew macht heute klar wir wollen bachmut
entschieden verteidigen Henna Hebestreit
ist in der Ukraine
im Tiefflug durch das Kampfgebiet
ukrainische Piloten zielen auf russische
Nachschublinien wollen demonstrieren wie
präzise sie immer noch zuschlagen können
auch die russische Seite ist an der
Propaganda Front aktiv
gezeigt werden nur gefallen Ukraine
[Musik]
von einem dieser toten Soldaten hat sich
Kia jüngst feierlich verabschiedet der
Metro kurz zu beilo einer der
bekanntesten bataillonskommandeure der
Ukraine ist im Kampf um bachmut gefallen
er wurde gerade 27 Jahre alt auf dem
Maidan erweisen sie ihm die letzte Ehre
viele Menschen Jungs Leben gekommen sind
auch mein Neffe ist tot Menschen mit
denen ich an der Front war
am Anfang ist das schwer zu verarbeiten
aber dann versteht man
weitergehen muss
seit 382 Tagen ist die Ukraine schon im
Kampf gegen den russischen Aggressor wie
in vielen anderen Teilen des Landes fern
der Front haben sie auch in Kiew gelernt
dem Krieg immer wieder für einige
Momente auszublenden
immer sonntags treffen sie sich hier zum
Tango Argentino die Musik zeugt von
Fernweh von Sehnsucht nach einer anderen
Umgebung und nach einer anderen
Situation
[Musik]
für mich ist Tango emotionale
Entspannung du kannst umschalten und
kannst eine fremde Person umarmen und
kannst fühlen dass du nicht alleine bist
in dieser Welt und das hilft sehr
mir geht es besser wenn ich mich auf den
Tag unter den Abend freue an dem ich die
Möglichkeit habe zu tanzen
Tango hilft Ihnen durch den Kriegsalltag
mit ihrem Tanz helfen sie aber auch
denen die ihre Freiheit mit der Waffe
verteidigen
wir unseren tangieren
sie ihre kleinen Fluchten auch gegen
jene die Tanzen im Krieg vielleicht als
taktlos empfinden
wenn wir keine Kultur mehr haben wofür
kämpfen wir dann soll Winston Churchill
mal gesagt haben
noch ein Thema jetzt um das sich der
schnelllebige Nachrichten Journalismus
auch dauerhaft kümmern muss aber
millionenfach ist dieses Land zumindest
der größte Teil von uns gegen Corona
geimpft Ärzte impfkommissionen und die
Politik haben das so dringend empfohlen
manche wollten die Impfung sogar zur
Pflicht machen klar ist aber
millionenfach haben diese Impfungen
schwere Schäden verhindert klar ist aber
auch sie haben in Einzelfällen auch
Nebenwirkungen nur dass darüber bislang
kaum gesprochen wird betroffene
berichten wie sie komplett allein
gelassen werden
kommende Woche sollte der erste
Zivilprozess starten wegen solcher
mutmaßlicher Schäden gegen die Firma
biontech er wurde auf Ende April
verschoben ich spreche gleich mit dem
Bundesgesundheitsminister erst Susanna
Santina und Menschen bei denen die
Impfung das Leben verändert hat nur ganz
anders als gedacht
ja ich war mein Lieblingsgerät dein
Lieblingsgerät das weiß ich zweieinhalb
Jahre ist es her dass Seline in der
ersten Liga nicht nur am barenturnte die
17-Jährige war sehr erfolgreich nahm am
deutschen turnfestteil alles änderte
sich als sie sich zum zweiten Mal mit
dem coved Impfstoff von biontech impfen
dies sie erkrankte kurz danach so schwer
es sich nicht mehr laufen konnte nicht
mehr richtig schlucken konnte meine
Augen nicht mehr öffnen konnte
Doppelbilder gesehen habe
Schwierigkeiten im atmen und dann wurde
ich richtig auch erst dann ernst
genommen
ein Jahr lang verbrachte Selen im
Krankenhaus kämpfte mehrfach um ihr
Leben weil sie nach der Impfung schwere
Gefäßschäden und Blutgerinnsel erlitt
seit fünf Wochen ist Celine wieder zu
Hause zurück liegt ein Jahr voller Angst
und Kämpfe um die richtige Behandlung
die Übernahme der Kosten und die
Anerkennung als im Schaden erst vor
kurzem hat das Land Nordrhein-Westfalen
anerkannt dass Celine schwerer
Erkrankung durch den impfstoffkominati
von biontech verursacht wurde sie
bekommt eine monatliche
Versorgungsleistung von 854 €. doch das
reiche nicht
wir haben kein normales Leben mehr und
dafür finde ich nicht nur das Land NRW
wir sind dankbar wir sind froh aber
biontech hat uns das angetan
doch bei yontech lehnt jede
Verantwortung ab versteht rechtlich
wurden die impfersteller in eine sehr
gute Lage versetzt im Vertrag mit der EU
2020 wurden sie nämlich von jeder
Haftung befreit brisant auch dass dort
selbst auf die hohen Risiken der
kurvitimpfung hingewiesen wurde
ungeachtet der Bemühungen erkennen die
Parteien an dass sich der Impfstoff zum
Zeitpunkt der Unterzeichnung in der
klinischen Erprobung der Phase 3
befindet und dass er möglicherweise
nicht zugelassen wird
die Risiken also unkalkulierbar sagt
Rechtsanwalt Ulbrich weil eine bedingte
Zulassung ja beinhaltet dass dem
Hersteller nachgelassen wird erst
künftig die Unbedenklichkeit des Stoffes
nachweisen zu dürfen und gleichwohl ist
dann die Bundesrepublik Deutschland nach
vorne geprescht und hat diesen als
wirksam und sicher ohne tatsächliche
Anhaltspunkte für ihre Aussage
getroffen auch Christian Pilz im Schaden
wurde nach einem Jahr anerkannt vom Land
Bayern der Rechtsanwalt erlitt nach der
Impfung mit wachseria von Astra Seneca
eine Brücken Wehen Thrombose und musste
wieder laufen und sprechen lernen jetzt
ist der teilweise blind und lebt mit
einem Implantat im Kopf
es fühlt sich an wie ein zu kleiner
Stahlhelm drückt wahnsinnig vor allem
auf die empfindlichen Stellen also das
Leben ist tatsächlich nicht mehr
wirklich toll muss ich muss ich sagen
also im Gegenteil rund 520 Euro
monatlich soll Christian vom Land nun
bekommen ein hohen sagt der er klagt
dagegen und gegen den impfversteller
niemand könne wieder gut machen was
Selin und die gesamte Familie durch die
Impfung erleiden mussten sagt ihre
Mutter
auch der Staat sollte jetzt endlich mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen
der Bundesgesundheitsminister ist bei
uns vielen Dank dafür und guten Abend
Karl Lauterbach guten Abend herzlich was
was sagen sie denn diesen Betroffenen
zunächst einmal diese Schicksale sind
absolut bestürzend und jedes einzelne
Schicksal ist 1 zu viel und die Menschen
tun mir ehrlich gesagt auch sehr leid
das sind schwerste
Einschränkungen und davon wird auch
einiges permanent sein von daher ist das
schwierig was wir als Staat machen ist
die Krankenkassen übernehmen hat die
Behandlungskosten und also die Länder
bezahlen wenn die Versorgung notwendig
ist die Versorgungskosten aber
tatsächlich haben wir auf beiden Seiten
Probleme weil die Medikamente für eine
Behandlung die haben wir noch nicht an
denen wird fieberhaft geforscht und die
Versorgungsansprüche die sind oft sehr
eng geschnürt von daher verstehe ich
tatsächlich die Menschen die also sich
hier beklagen
jetzt tun sie so ein bisschen so auch
als ob eigentlich alles geregelt wäre
aber wenn man mit diesem Menschen redet
hört man genau das Gegenteil ein Jahr
kämpfen immer wieder abgewiesen werden
viele Stellen die einem keinen Glauben
schenken manchmal sogar überhaupt nicht
mal eine Antwort bekommen und dann
Spießrutenlauf bis zur Anerkennung als
Impfschaden und am Ende eine kleine
Summe das kann es doch nicht sein was
der Staat aktuell diesen Menschen bietet
oder auf keinen Fall und ich will auch
nicht diesen Eindruck erwecken denn das
ist nicht der also das ist nicht wie ich
die Dinge sehe es muss also hier zu
einem schnelleren anerkennen dieser
Verfahren diese also im Schellen kommen
und wir bekommen ja jetzt auch langsam
an klareres Bild man muss allerdings
auch darauf hinweisen nur dass kein
falscher Eindruck hier hängen bleibt
schwere im Schäden sind auf der
Grundlage der Daten des
paul-ehrlich-institutes oder der
europäischen Zulassungsbehörde in der
Größenordnung von weniger als 1 zu
10.000 Impfungen somit ist es nicht so
dass das so häufig ist aber weil die
Bilder also der Krankheit ich hier ist
immer klarer abzeichnen müsste es in
Zukunft auch möglich sein diejenigen die
betroffen sind schneller zu
identifizieren so dass auch schneller
geholfen werden kann warum haben Sie
Herr Lauterbach im Sommer 2021 noch
behauptet dass die Impfung
nebenwirkungsfrei sein naja das war eine
Übertreibung also die ich da einmal in
einem missglückten Tweet gemacht habe
aber es war ja nicht grundsätzlich meine
Haltung ich hatte ja sehr sehr häufig
vorher auch schon zu den Nebenwirkungen
der Impfungen Stellung genommen sie
haben zum Beispiel sehr wir haben aber
auch häufig danach noch gesagt es gebe
kaum oder praktisch gar keine halt mehr
oder weniger nebenwirkungsfrei haben sie
danach in einer Fernsehsendung von Anne
Will noch mal gesagt also sie haben
schon immer diesen Eindruck erweckt dass
das Thema Nebenwirkungen eigentlich gar
kein Thema ist na das ist nicht richtig
also ich habe es ja eben gesagt also die
Zahlen waren mir ja die Zeit bekannt die
sind auch relativ stabil geblieben diese
Impfstoffe sind ja weltweit eingesetzt
worden 1 zu 10.000 da kann man jetzt
sagen dass es viel und man kann sagen es
ist nicht so viel aber es ist ja
tatsächlich eine Impfung die vor sehr
schwerer Krankheit schützt und übrigens
sehr häufig dann auch das long
kovetrisiko also senkt das hat ja
Ähnlichkeit mit dem was wir hier gesehen
haben mit dem postfakt-syndrom somit
also die Impfungen der Nutzen überwiegt
aber es ist richtig eins zu 10.000 das
ist die Häufigkeit von schweren
Nebenwirkungen jetzt stehen die ersten
Klagen an gegen bei und hält auch gegen
andere Impfstoffhersteller was glauben
Sie wie die ausgehen werden ich kann
nicht spekulieren das ist nicht meine
Aufgabe als Minister muss ich also da
vorsichtig sein richtig ist dass also im
Rahmen dieser EU Verträge damals die
Unternehmen weitest gehend aus der
Haftung befreit worden sind und dass
daher die Haftung also beim deutschen
Staat liegt also quasi bei wie eben
beschrieben bei den Ländern aber
Krankenkassen was das allerwichtigste
ist
nach vorne blickend ist wir brauchen
eine Behandlung und ich werde also mit
dem Bundesgesundheitsministerium werde
ich ein Programm auflegen wo wir also
die Folgen von lonkovit und also das
wären dann auch Postfach wäre dann mit
betroffen wo wir dies also untersuchen
und auch die Versorgung verbessern das
ist ein Beitrag den wir leisten können
wann kommt denn das ganz konkret fragen
ja gerade diese Betroffenen die die
ganze Zeit hingehalten werden das stimmt
aber ich verhandle mit dem
Haushaltsausschuss und also es ist
tatsächlich also ein Programm was ich so
schnell wie möglich auflegen möchte und
ich bin quasi in den
Haushaltsverhandlungen für dieses Geld
es ist etwas was wir also auch bringen
müssen wo wir in der Pflicht sind und
das würde die Experten in diesem Bereich
so vernetzen dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit
einer wirklich guten Therapie in
Deutschland wachsen würde jetzt haben
sie gerade diesen Haftungsausschluss
selbst angesprochen davon der führt ja
dazu dass die Pharmafirmen in all diesen
Gerichtsverfahren sich quasi
zurücklehnen können weil nämlich der
Staat das Risiko übernommen hat die der
muss dann also sie die Bundesregierung
für solche
Schadensersatzforderungen die dem sich
möglicherweise ergeben gerade stehen ist
das ein gutes Gefühl dass sie damit
haben was heißt ein gutes Gefühl
zunächst einmal ich habe die Verträge
damals nicht gemacht sondern bin in
dieser Verträge was man Amt angeht
hinein gewachsen und ich glaube das ist
der damaligen Situation
geschuldet ist dass man damals so
schnell wie möglich die Impfstoffe
nutzen wollte und da ist der Staat also
in die Haftung gegangen vielleicht war
das auch richtig denn es ist besser dass
der Staat also haftet als wenn mit
Firmen lange dann vergleiche oder
Prozesse geführt werden müssen und wie
schwierig es ist vom Staat tatsächlich
Geld zu bekommen haben wir ja gerade
gesehen was glauben Sie denn wie es
jetzt dann weitergeht meinen sie dass
Firmen zum Beispiel angesichts der
Situation zum Beispiel in einer
freiwillige Stiftung Geld einzahlen
könnten wäre das eine Idee wenn sie
schon aus der Haftung draußen sind ein
es wäre auf jeden Fall wertvoll wenn die
also Firmen hier eine ja Beteiligung
zeigen würden denn die Gewinne sind ja
exorbitant gewesen exorbitante Gewinne
und somit also wäre das tatsächlich mehr
als eine gute Geste sondern es könnte
man erwarten aber sie fragen mich wie
wird das Weitergehen ich sag mal das
optimistisches Szenario was ich habe ist
dass wir endlich lernen wie wir
longkowith und Postfach wie wir das
behandeln können wie wir das hinbekommen
und das Land nicht darüber hinaus die
Fälle schneller anerkennen so dass die
Menschen nicht so lange darauf warten
müssen überhaupt was Brust [__]
anerkannt zu werden ein Versprechen des
Bundesgesundheitsministers Karl
Lauterbach vielen Dank für das Gespräch
heute abend ich danke Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir so um 18 Uhr
heute abend aufgezeichnet ein
ausführlichen Film meiner Kollegin
Susanna Santina über Menschen mit
Impfschäden finden Sie online in der ZDF
Mediathek oder unter ZDF heute.de
so Hannah du hast jetzt einen ersten
Blick auf das was heute auch noch
wichtig ist ja der Bundestag soll
schrumpfen von 736 auf dauerhaft 630
Abgeordnete darauf haben sich die
Spitzen von SPD Grünen und FDP jetzt
offenbar geeinigt allerdings müssen die
Fraktionen der Ampel noch zustimmen dass
er vor das ZDF aus Koalitionskreisen
schon Ende der nächsten Woche könnte die
Wahlrechtsreform dann vom Bundestag
beschlossen werden im ursprünglichen
Entwurf war noch eine Verkleinerung auf
598 Sätze vorgesehen
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck und
Agrarminister ist dem mir sind zu Gast
in Brasilien um die
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu vertiefen und
Grüne Wertschöpfungsketten auszubauen
bei den Gesprächen soll es auch darum
gehen dass Freihandelsabkommen der EU
mit den südamerikanischen merkursstaaten
voranzubringen während ihrer sechs
tägigen Reise werden die beiden Minister
auch Kolumbien besuchen
der französische Senat hat trotz
anhaltender Massenproteste für die
geplante Rentenreform geschwemmt
Frankreichs Ministerpräsidentin born
sagte dies sei ein entscheidender Etappe
die Regierung hofft das bereits am
Donnerstag endgültig über das Vorhaben
abgestimmt wird der Senat belichte die
Pläne zwar mit großer Mehrheit in der
Nationalversammlung ist der Ausgang
allerdings ungewiss auch gestern
protestierten wieder hunderttausende
gegen die Reform die unter anderem
vorsieht das Renteneintrittsalter
schrittweise von 62 auf 64 Jahre
anzuheben
nach Angaben der israelischen Armee sind
im Westjordanland in der Nähe von Nablus
drei bewaffnete Palästinenser getötet
worden eine vierte Person wurde
festgenommen die Männer hätten zuvor
einen israelischen Militärposten
angegriffen hieß es in einer
Stellungnahme vor allem im West
jordanland eskaliert seit Wochen die
Gewalt seit Jahresbeginn wurden bislang
mindestens 80 Palästinenser getötet
unter ihnen militante aber auch
Zivilisten und Kinder auf israelischer
Seite starben mindestens 12 Zivilisten
und jetzt 4 endlose aber nicht mehr
unergründliche Weiten der Sternenhimmel
er ist immer derselbe aber er sieht für
uns hier auf der Erde immer anders aus
im Norden von Chile wo die Luft so
trocken und so klar ist wie kaum
irgendwo sonst treibt einem der Blick
nach oben Tränen in die Augen weil das
was man sieht einfach überwältigend ist
deshalb pilgert auch die Wissenschaft
hierher um ins Universum zu blicken am
besten natürlich wenn kein Licht stört
das größte
astronomieprojekt auf Erden feiert
seinen zehnten Geburtstag Elisabeth zu
Eulenburg nimmt uns mit in Regionen in
denen neue Sterne geboren werden
5000 Meter hoch in der Atacama-Wüste
thront das Alma Teleskop auf der Suche
nach unseren kosmischen Ursprüngen hat
es Unsichtbares sichtbar gemacht
Geburten von Sternen und Planeten und
auch beim ersten Foto eines Schwarzen
Lochs war das Teleskop dabei
die Forschenden Visu seiner randai
brauchen hier oben Sauerstoff war die
Luft so dünn ist für die Messungen sind
die Höhe und Trockenheit ideal
die Antennen müssen 5000 Metern stehen
weil wir im Millimeter und Sub
Millimeter Bereich arbeiten das ist ein
Teil des Lichtspektrums den mit unseren
Augen nicht sehen können und der von der
Atmosphäre absorbiert wird das heißt der
trinkt sehr schlecht durch die
Atmosphäre hindurch hier oben ist die
Atmosphäre durchlässig und die 66
Antennen des Radioteleskops können ihre
volle Kraft entfalten in flexiblen
Konfigurationen können Sie zu einem
riesen Teleskop verbunden werden bis zu
16 km groß
die Antennen können hoch gehoben werden
von speziellen Transportern und auf
diese Pads platziert werden diese
Spezialfahrzeuge können die 100 Tonnen
schweren Antennen Millimeter genau
versetzen und sicher transportieren auch
in den Hangar hier unten auf 3000 Metern
hier werden sie gewartet
in diesem blauen Zylinder befinden sich
die Instrumente das krasse ist jetzt
dass diese Instrumente auf vier Kelvin
gekühlt werden müssen als auf
269 Grad Celsius nur so gelingt die
Messung im kalten Universum John
Carpenter ist forschungsschef von Alma
er hat sichtbar gemacht wie Planeten
entstehen und forscht daran weiter
wir versuchen jetzt das chemische
Netzwerk der Planeten Entstehung zu
verstehen und prüfen ob die Zutaten für
die Entstehung von Leben schon von
Beginn an vorhanden sind
die Forschung macht hier nicht Halt am
anderen Ende der Wüste entsteht gerade
das größte optische Teleskop der Erde
das extreme large Teleskope das Ziel in
Atmosphären von Exoplaneten nach Leben
suchen wirklich riesengroß das ganze hat
einen Durchmesser von 60 m aber das
nichts im Vergleich dazu wie die Kuppel
dieses Teleskops aussehen wird wenn sie
fertig ist die wird nämlich 85 Meter
hoch sein
wie schon zu Zeiten von Galileo und
Kepler hat die Astronomie mit ihrem
Teleskopen auch heute das Potenzial das
Weltbild zu wandeln und unser
Verständnis vom Leben dem Universum und
dem ganzen Rest für immer zu verändern
um das Teleskop selbst zu verstehen muss
man sich einfach mal vorstellen dass es
Bilder macht auf denen man einen
Golfball erkennen würde aus 15
Kilometern Entfernung
Hannah wo bist du du bleibst noch beim
Thema im weitesten Sinne das kann man so
sagen noch nach gut fünf Monaten an Bord
der Internationalen Raumstation ISS sind
zwei US-Amerikaner eine Russin und ein
Japaner zurück auf der Erde an Bord
einer Dragon Kapsel des Raumfahrt
Unternehmen SpaceX landeten sie im Golf
von Mexiko vor der Küste Floridas wegen
schlechten Wetters musste die Crew
mehrere Tage auf den Rückflug warten
ihre Ablösung war bereits vor mehr als
einer Woche auf der ISS eingetroffen
in der Fußball-Bundesliga trafen an
diesem Sonntag der SC Freiburg und die
TSG Hoffenheim aufeinander entstand 2:1
die Hoffenheimer beenden den Spieltag
damit als Tabellenletzter außerdem
spielte Werder Bremen gegen Bayer
Leverkusen und unterlag zwei drei und
das Abendspiel VfL Wolfsburg gegen Union
Berlin endete unentschieden 1:1
beim Weltcup im norwegischen Oslo haben
es die deutschen Nordischen Kombinierer
Vinzenz Geiger und Julian Schmid aufs
Podest geschafft nach dem Springen von
der Großschanze belegten Geiger und
Schmied zunächst die Plätze 8 und 4 mit
starker Leistung in der Loipe konnten
sie sich die beiden Oberstdorfer dann
aber letztendlich noch die Plätze
zweiunddreißigern der Sieg ging an den
Topf Favoriten yahl Magnus Riva aus
Norwegen
während in der Ukraine ein ganz realer
Krieg tobt feiert Hollywood ein
anti-kriegsdrama im Kino nach der
Vorlage von Erich Maria Marx Buch geht
im Westen nichts Neues ins Rennen um die
Oscars und hat so viele Chancen wie noch
nie zuvor ein deutscher Film das Buch
von remark und die erste Verfilmung
waren in Nazi Deutschland verboten der
Autor ging ins Exil auch nach Los
Angeles exakt dorthin wo sie heute Nacht
mit fiebern wenn es heißt
ausgerechnet die fröhlich bunte Vivian
hat einen düsteren Oskar Favoriten
warum nur fragen wir
es war unglaublich also wenn man mitten
im Krieg wäre so haben sie ihn gefilmt
man fühlt die Qual der Soldaten die im
Dreck sinnlos sterben
im Westen nichts Neues
unglaublich brutal so wirklichkeitsnavi
möglich ist das erste Weltkriegs Epos
geworden wir haben 16 Stunden am Tag
gedreht bei immer so fünf Grad Celsius
ungefähr von oben bis unten durch Nest
und mit 45 Kilo Gewichts an Kostümen und
Equipment dass der Netflix Film nun für
9 Oscars nominiert ist liegt vielleicht
daran dass deutsche Kriegsfilme eben
nicht so sind nicht so sein können wie
andere meint der Regisseur wir können
keine Helden haben die eine Mission
erfüllen und erfolgreich dabei sind wir
können nur Menschen verfolgen die
zerbrochen werden und
unzerbrechen gleichzeitig und und Gewalt
in die Welt tragen und den Gewalt
angetan wird das ist anders bei
Hollywood Kriegsfilmen und anderen
kassenknülern aber auch das verrückt
verwirrende Drama everything everywhere
all at once könnte bester Film werden
Mama
kulturstaatsministerin Roth ist
optimistisch
so wie alle Gäste beim Empfangen der
Villa Aurora die Macher ahnten bei der
Produktion noch nichts vom ukraine-krieg
aber wollten warnen aus Sorge um die
Demokratie die seit Jahren durch
Rechtspopulisten und ihre Lügen bedroht
werden
das ist eine Rhetorik die sich Björn
höckes AFD teilt mit Putin mit Trump mit
bolsonaro und mit Orban und wir hielten
ist für relevant
den Film zu machen und daran zu erinnern
was passieren kann wenn man dieser Form
von rechter Propaganda nicht sofort
entgegentritt die Chancen stehen gut
hier denn die Filmakademie will in neuem
Licht erscheinen moderner vielfältiger
selbst der nicht mehr rote sondern er
graue Teppich signalisiert weniger Drama
mehr Relevanz als letztes Jahr als Will
Smith feige für Chris Rock stärker
nachhalte als der beste Film Vivien ist
heute noch empört
[Musik]
wissen ist für uns in l.a und außer auf
diese Oskar Nacht gucken wir natürlich
auch weiter in die kommende Woche hier
ist wie immer am Sonntag der heute
journal Ausblick von Björn weitner
[Musik]
am Montag wird in Peking der Nationale
Volkskongress enden und die Delegierten
werden die größte Regierungsumbildung
seit zehn Jahren formell absegnen im
neuen Führungszirkel werden dann vor
allem enge Vertraute vom alten und neuen
Staatschef skising-ping sein
am Dienstag wird Eva Högl als
werbeauftragte des Bundes ihren
Jahresbericht vorlegen und damit die
Sicht der Soldaten auf eine Bundeswehr
für die es nach jahrelanger
Unterfinanzierung zwar große Aufgaben
aber deutlich zu wenig Ausrüstung gibt
ebenfalls am Dienstag werden
Lehrermangel Digitalisierung und
frühkindliche Bildung Thema sein beim
Bildungsgipfel in Berlin und Länder
Kommunen und Wissenschaft werden beraten
wie die großen Baustellen im
Bildungssystem anzugehen sind
am Donnerstag wird in Ruandas Hauptstadt
kigalide FIFA Kongress Gianni in fantino
als Präsidenten wieder wählen egal wie
Deutschland sich verhält
vom Zerwürfnis über die one love-binde
in Katar und angekündigter fundamental
Opposition blieb zuletzt nur der Hinweis
von DFB-Chef Neuendorf dass man auf
Fragen zu umstrittenen Themen nun
Antworten von Infantino erwarte
und jetzt der Blick auf die teils
ungewöhnlich milden Wetteraussichten
morgen im Süden länger sonnig sonst
wechselnd oder stark bewölkt und
zeitweise Regen am Nachmittag im Westen
und Südwesten einzelne Gewitter dazu
starker Wind im Nordwesten und im
Bergland Sturmböen sehr mild mit
Höchstwerten zwischen 11 und 22 Grad
auch am Dienstag sehr wechselhaft und
stürmisch bei 8 bis 14 Grad am Mittwoch
viele Schnee und Regenschauer und nur
noch 4 bis 9 Grad erst am Donnerstag
wieder deutliche Wetter Beruhigung
wildes Wetter da ist wirklich alles
dabei das war unser Sonntag hier im
heute journal im Namen des gesamten
Teams danke dass Sie dabei waren ab
morgen sind hier Marietta Slomka und
Heinz Wolf für Sie da und die nächsten
Nachrichten gibt's hier gegen 0:35 Uhr
heute Express mit Antoine Abend tschüss
[Musik]